أقيم حفل التقاء السنوي في نيويورك
، وفي أكبر ليلة في
الكونجرس ألكسندريا أوكاسيو-كورتيز ، اغتنمت أكبر عضوة في الكونجرس للأزياء
الفرصة للإدلاء ببيان
أنها كانت ترتدي ثوبًا أبيض يقرأ
على ظهره ضريبة الأغنياء وقد أثار هذا الزي
ردود فعل متباينة من
الجمهور  للترويج للرسالة في
حدث تكلف أكثر من ثلاثين
ألف دولار لكل تذكرة تنضم إلي
الآن هي المرأة التي صممت ثوب
aurora
james عفواً إنها المؤسسة
والمديرة الإبداعية لـ Brother vellies
aurora ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك وحصلنا على
رؤية  أنت هناك أيضًا
على السجادة الحمراء واقفًا إلى جانب
إبداعك هناك ، وأتساءل أنك تعرف
الأشياء الأولى أولاً ، هل يمكنك فقط إخبارنا
بالقصة الخلفية لكيفية تصميمك
هذا
نعم بالطبع ،
لذا عندما يتعلق الأمر بتزيين
عضو الكونجرس لهذا الحدث
أنت تعلم أنني أردت أن أجعل شيئًا
مميزًا لها حقًا ، وفي
النهاية يمكنني أن أتراجع ،
هل يمكنني التراجع فقط كيف فعلت
هل تعرفها ، أعني كيف فعلت ذلك ج  ربما
تم اختيارك للقيام بذلك
بشكل جيد ، أعتقد أننا كنا على دراية
بعمل بعضنا البعض لفترة قصيرة ، لقد
بدأت عملي هنا
في نيويورك مع 3500 في سوق السلع المستعملة
وأم عندما كانت لا تزال تسقي
كانت تتابع عملي وكانت
متحمسة للغاية عندما فزت بشيء يسمى
صندوق الأزياء cfda vogue فقط أنت
تعرف كونك فتاة من الطبقة العاملة
ومهاجرة هنا في نيويورك تطلق
علامة تجارية للأزياء لم يسمع بها من قبل
للوصول إلى المراتب العليا  من
الأزياء الفاخرة وقد اتبعت حقًا
مسيرتي المهنية ، وقررنا
التعاون في هذا المظهر
جيدًا ، لذا فأنت تتعاون في
المظهر وتخبرنا كيف تتصور
هذا التصميم
جيدًا ، فأنت تعلم جيدًا
أن حفل التقاء هو واحد من
أكثرها تميزًا  الأحداث في العالم
وأردنا القدوم وإيصال
رسالة وأعتقد أنه عندما نتحدث عن التضمين
والوصول إلى الغرف المغلقة
للأشخاص الملونين عندما تحصل أخيرًا على
مقعد على الطاولة ، عليك أن تقرر
ما  الرسالة هي أنك تريد
إيصالها ، وأعتقد أنه
بالنسبة لعضوة الكونغرس ، أعتقد أن
المساواة الاقتصادية والعدالة الاقتصادية
كانت نوعًا ما في قمة اهتماماتنا وفرض الضرائب على
الأغنياء حقًا ما استقرنا عليه ،
لذلك هناك الكثير
من الأثرياء في هذا الحدث
حضوره مكلف
للغاية وهو حصري بشكل لا يصدق
آه
وهناك أشخاص خاصة على
اليمين ينتقدون
عضوة الكونجرس قائلين
إنها توجه هذه الرسالة ولكن
هذا حدث هزلي يكلف ما يزيد عن
30 ألف تذكرة. ما كان رد
فعلك تجاه  رد الفعل العنيف ،
استمع جيدًا ، أعتقد في النهاية أن الكثير من
هذه المحادثات التي لدينا حول
العدالة الاقتصادية تحدث عادةً في
أماكن مع أفراد من الطبقة العاملة
وأعتقد أن عضوة الكونغرس لن
تضحي بأخلاقها أبدًا من أجل
الراحة وأرادت التأكد من أن هذه
الرسالة  تم إحضارهم إلى تلك الغرفة
وإلى مجموعة من الأشخاص الذين
يتعين عليهم في النهاية أن يكونوا على استعداد لأن
يكونوا أكثر
ليبرالية من خلال أعمالهم الاقتصادية
حسنًا أيضًا ، وأعتقد أن هذا ما
فعلناه ، ولكي أكون صادقًا معك ،
لم تكن لتحضر وتلبس فقط
ثوبًا جميلًا دون إرسال
أي نوع من الرسائل إلى الناس وأنت
تعلم أن الموضة غالبًا ما يُنظر إليها على أنها  هذا
شيء تافه حقًا
ولكن في النهاية في علامتي التجارية وبالنسبة للكثير
من المصممين الآخرين ، نستخدمه كأداة قوية حقًا
للتواصل
خاصة النساء ذوات البشرة الملونة ، لقد كنت
مصممًا مستدامًا منذ أن بدأت في عام
2013 ، كما استخدمت شركتي لإطلاق
واحدة  من أسرع المؤسسات غير الربحية نموًا
في أمريكا الآن التعهد الخامس عشر
وهو حقًا يتعلق بالحصول على إمكانية الوصول التي
لديك
ومشاركة رسالة وأعتقد أن
هذا ما فعلته وفي
النهاية يمكننا طرح هذه الأفكار في
سياسات الثقافة الشعبية  سيتبع ذلك أيضًا